[Music]
all right so there is a the National
Health Service in the UK has just
launched a pilot version of a
breakthrough weight loss drug right
where you literally inject yourself and
this weight loss jab reduces your body
weight by up to 15% it's now available
to the public what is this [__] Z oh
yeah OIC part two or something it's
getting really popular they're doing
these don't take it guys don't it just
helps slow down your digestion to the
point where like a couple of my clients
take it and some of them they'll feel
nauseous when they they eat fried food
slows your digestion yeah so it just
slows everything down so then you just
stay Fuller for longer so you just don't
really want to eat so it's like appetite
suppress I think that's that's the one
that's how OIC works I think but makes
the way that uh the way to approach
things I really liked how Andrew
huberman broke it down he goes if you
have an
issue with yourself
try to exhaust all behavioral remedies
before you go through prescription or
hormonal because there is no such thing
as like a free biological lunch yeah
anything you do here is going to do
something somewhere else so with the
current one OIC I've heard it destroys
your butt biome I've heard it where it
actually does reduce your weight but it
actually but biome that's what I said
but but biome you said butt
biome you like an expert and just noded
but we couldn't get away with it but I
made eye contact with immediately wait
what gut biome it's your gut and your
butt and then um it does reduce your
overall weight but it actually increases
your body fat percentage huh so that's
the opposite of what you want you don't
want to go from like 150 to 13 but then
go from 20% body fat to 30% body fat so
but that sounds like too much talking
and thinking for a lot of people you
know what I mean they just want some
hydroxy cut you know some Fen so because
the appetite suppressant so powerful I
think another problem some people might
experience is what happens when they get
off of it what happens appetite like do
you did you create those habits to be
able to sustain your new weight or is
your appetite going to upregulate and
then you're going to be like I need to
eat [__] everything cuz you do see
that happen with people that like cut a
bunch of weight and they do it probably
not in the best way and then once they
stop dieting they just got to get
[__] or like the dudes that are on
steroids they come off all of their
[__] titty Square milk and [__] you
want that yeah you want that Anthony
maybe all right you are speaking from
like a professional nutritionist point
of view and some people just want the
[__] answer yeah I I just hear this
yeah Different Strokes for just get the
pill then yeah this is actually an
actual jab like a shot and it's called
wigi W VY uh and we're sponsored by them
so make sure
that no the funny think is in the fine
print though when they're talking about
clinical trials and stuff like that um a
new weight loss injection has been found
to lead up to a 15% reduction in body
mass in clinical trials when it's used
alongside changes in diet physical
activity and behavioral support so you
still have to do all the other stuff
right as that goes with everything
that's like the freaking um the cereal
commercial where they put the grapefruit
and the milk and all that [__] next to
the picture and they're like part of a
balanc breakfast part of a balance cuz
that's even with Aderall right like oh
this thing makes me smart yeah but you
still got to read while you take it you
can't [__] take it and go oh I'm
getting [__] real you still got to do
some [__] that's like the back of a
[__] Douro Pizza it's like have it
with a salad it's like dude nobody's
doing this I'm eating two of these
tonight literally
nobody little garden salad with a salad
so stupid as a wise man once said it
isn't going to suck itself yep there's
also that who was
itle dude
Anthony how often do you have to get the
Iceberg
Slim like one time thing it depends on
the medication like depending on the
dosage so like some people depending on
how much weight you have to lose or what
the doctor kind of talks to about
they'll give you higher dosage you
probably take more frequently but I
don't know the exact dosage for people
some of my clients they do it like once
every other week or so but they're on a
low dosage if there ever was a quick
answer like this that had no negative
side
effect you do it I think it's on its way
I think this is the first stage of it
being like being better you like [__]
nanotech that goes in there and just
eats belly fat I think there's another
weight loss drug that they're doing
because I think the big argument with
like oepic some of these weight loss
drugs is that like what Barb was saying
you lose a bunch of weight but a lot of
it is proportionate body fat and muscle
and usually it's like a body composition
thing we want people to have more more
muscle than fat obviously so they'll be
healthier but it drops your uh muscle
and also thins your tendons so that's
not very good either cuz some people
just don't your T how do you know this
sh dropping body weight isn't cuz I'm
I'm a
comedian study these my bad my bad moded
and and sometimes too it's it's such a
powerful appetite sprent this is just
from some people that I know that are
taking it they just don't eat at all so
it's like they can go the whole day
without eating and they just contining
like just losing just crappy Health
generally exactly so it's just like it
allows if you don't fix your health
habits you still are going to practice
your poor Habits Like if you didn't have
the OIC how would you lose the weight
it's kind of easier though to binge
watch a a TV series and then take pills
definitely rather than going to the gym
it's 100% easier but then again I think
at the end of it some people may not get
what they're looking for with the drug
you know like cuz you got to think long
term on some of the stuff I think that's
true if you want a booty build you still
got a booty build if I eat an entire
frozen pizza normally Garden salad no no
normally just normally but then I'm like
you know what I should be healthier I'm
going to eat an entire frozen pizza and
a
salad that's healthy right that's being
healthier no that's that's a step
towards more Health abely not
dude hey just instead of having the
whole pizza have 34s of the pizza how
about that start there you know but I
had the salad after what that's cool
that's like when you go to McDonald's
but you have a extra large Diet Coke cuz
you're
healthy that's still kind of works
though you know it does work you ever
watch those [__] lipo videos where
they're just [__] jabbing the giant
needle and they person like that's crazy
just sucking out Globs of fat dude
that's crazy but even that you there's
like a protocol you have to do with that
too like I've had clients who who've
done like lipo section and they have a
very they do like the they the stomach
stapling too oh yeah like they have a
very strict protocol where you have to
even measure the like the amount of
water you could drink a day so it's like
you're still [__] tracking food
anyway you know what I mean so it's like
it does look pretty trippy when when
people get lipo and stuff but like cuz I
have friends that have gotten like
massive lipo but then they still have
like big faces or like fat
hands cuz you can't you can't like do
anything about that or like nice Lio but
you still got fat hands
how fat your wrists are it's like a
crazy thing cuz we were like analyzing
it we're like dude you can't really like
can you like lipo your hands F I
actually feel like uh like Japan has a
pretty good cuz their policy is um a lot
of the like their big corporations will
be like if your BMI or waist size is
past this we won't assure you so if you
don't care about your health why should
we and I'm like incentives like that's
kind of cool where it's crazy that I
love that it's like where it's like if
that was a combination of a lot of
bullying out there perfect health
perfect healing cuz why why else like
let's say you get through your own
actions and decisions you are like 200
lb overweight and then now you're like
okay insurance company your problem take
care of me you know and it's like dude
that's pretty crazy yeah I was just in
Japan for the last 2 weeks and we
actually had a conversation out there
cuz like Midway through the trip number
one there wasn't a day that went by that
I wasn't minimum doing 10,000 steps just
the out there and we actually had a
conversation cuz I was looking around I
was like number one difference there's
no [__] fat people everyone's walking
dude I I didn't see a single fat person
that wasn't a tourist well if you give
them a consequence like [__] I want
medical insurance yeah I think that's
cool like I wish America would do more
things to sneakily add stuff in like the
everyday
lifestyle to not get fat here because
our food and then our the way we eat
here is different from Japan right the
portions are bigger and then we just we
we wake up we sit at the breakfast table
we sit in our car and then we sit in our
office and then we sit during lunch
there's no like walking and the
healthier the food the more expensive it
is there's something in the food there's
something in the food for sure if you
look at how many homeless people here
are fat are we the only country are we
has fat people yeah something's up with
the food for sure then it's a weird time
where like back then poor people were
actually hungry but now the poor people
in America are fat well think about like
you 7eleven you can get a whole pizza
for like $1 yeah dude the amount of
times you brought up pizza is kind of
funny I'm just saying must Beck some
pizza now dude very
cheap there was this there's all these
videos too coming out of like these
people studying abroad right or like
Europeans coming to the US and they're
saying like I'm eating the same [__]
like I ate pizza I ate burgers or
whatever but then the kids that are
studying abroad in Europe they're
talking about how like I lost like like
25 lbs yeah and I'm like I'm not
changing what I do but I think it's cuz
well for one they all walk out there so
you're burning so many calories just
like going from pizza shop to to the bar
mhm or whatever and then two it's like I
think that they use different stuff um
they have different regulations in their
food like they don't use high fructose
corn syrup they don't use like um like a
lot sodium everywhere we do sodium in
every [__] thing preservatives all
that stuff like they have different
regulations yeah cuz they're not trying
to extend the shelf life to like 50
years of everything they put on there
yeah and then I'm I've been reading [__]
about how long it takes for synthetic
things to break down in your body so
when you combine that with the sugars
and all that stuff it just takes so much
longer for that to be processed and if
we're not moving yeah General lifestyle
seems to be the main most people don't
walk enough 100% like that's it and it's
hard to walk cuz like I enjoy walking
right but you have to go to a park to
walk some people don't live in
neighborhoods where it's not for them
you can't just walk around the block
can't go outside but also though too is
like people aren't really that creative
with finding ways to walk because who
wants to just pace around like a crazy
person yeah you go to you go to a casino
in Vegas and it tricks you you do like
25,000 steps and you don't even
know that's true actually like I know
some people like you were telling me
what he does when he's trying to get his
step count he just walks in place in
front of the TV how many people are
willing to do that PR know but I'm just
on the [__] flooor not a lot of
people are willing making sure his
tendons are thick or
[Laughter]
[Music]
whatever